in this short video we'll go through the
process of deploying a shiny for python
application from posit workbench so here
I am in vs code to posit connect
so just to give you a lay of the land so
what you're seeing right here is a shiny
for python application called app.pi and
that resides in a directory I've created
called shiny for python
so to get started let's go ahead and
install some packages we'll need for
this workflow so I'm going to use pip to
install the shiny package
also RS connect python which is used to
deploy applications to connect
and then you can see this application
depends on two popular data science
packages matplotlib and numpy so let's
make sure we install those as well
I believe I already have these in my
environment so it should say requirement
already satisfied so that's great we are
in a good spot
now before we deploy to posit connect
let's just make sure this application
runs correctly locally here within vs
code running on posit workbench
so I'll run a shiny run and the name of
the file app.pi hit enter
and we'll get a URL that I can then
click on
and here is our shiny for python
application it's a simple slider bar
that changes the number of bins in the
histogram as I move it left and right
all right so it appears to be working
well
and then the last thing we'll do is go
ahead and deploy it to posit connect and
we'll use the RS connect package to help
with this so RS connect deploy shiny you
have to give it the name of the connect
server you want to deploy to so I'll use
the dash n argument and I have the
server saved my environment as PCT prod
and then just give it the name of the
directory that houses the app.pi file
I'm currently within this directory so
I'll just use the period as a shorthand
and hit enter
it'll run through a few checks make sure
my environment is being captured and
recorded and sent to connect to
replicate that environment
and once that is done
it'll deploy to posit connect and we'll
get two URLs here at the bottom I can
click on this bottom one and it will
actually bring me straight to posit
connect and here we have that same
application running on the connect
instance
and that is how you can deploy a shiny
for python application to posit connect